this video is sponsored by mubi go to
movie.com thomasflight for your 30-day
extended free trial not everything is
some things are real
okay
there's a question that inevitably
arises when you watch the rehearsal and
that's how much of this is real to what
extent is what I'm seeing manipulated so
this is a camera in regards to the
production yes like it's same with the
timer I assume yeah the clock is a
countdown clock because this is an actor
and this is by Design the rehearsal
isn't really a reality TV show so much
as it is a show about a man making a
reality TV show we have to put on a hat
we have to put on a hat it's not going
to match do you have it Nathan Fielder
seems Above All Else intent on pulling
back the curtain on his own manipulation
and the manipulation and deception
inherent to creating this kind of TV in
the first place
but despite the fact that it feels like
the curtain is being pulled back for us
trying to untangle the question of how
much of the show is real feels more like
navigating a house of mirrors and the
reason it does has implications that I
think reach far beyond the scope of
reality television
you're you're a Willy Wonka on the
Chocolate Factory
um Charlie Bucket trying to get the I
don't remember the plot fully what did
Willy Wonka do was he good well he he
created a bad guy well he has some
questionable things but I'm Willy I'm
the bad guy well but he's a Dream Maker
that's wrong 240 volts
are you sure this is not causing any
lasting damage he sounds in like he's in
a lot of pain well the short smoking
people are not harmful this is a
recreation of something called the
Milgram experiment and it's being
performed by filmmaker and Illusionist
Darren Brown in his TV special The Heist
it's a fascinating experiment that goes
something like this you have two
subjects both are told they're
participating in an experiment about the
effects of punishment on learning
subject a is in one room reading test
questions and guided by the experimenter
while subject B is taking the test
unseen in a second room for every
question subject b gets wrong subject a
is instructed to administer an
electrical shock at increasing voltages
if they question whether or not the
experiment is safe the experimenter
urges them to continue so yeah then it's
someone will check on something it's
just he's not making any noise now and
he was before well I'm quite happy to go
on but just a bit worried about she
would continue
except there's a Twist the study isn't
about the effects of punishment on
learning it's actually about the effects
of authority on the participants
Behavior subject B is in on the
experiment and isn't actually hooked up
to anything
[Music]
he's in a lot of pain
it's a new place
the whole experiment is wild and the
original Milgram experiment a full 65
percent of the participants went on to
administer what they believed to be a
massive 450 volt shock even after the
fake subject in the other room had
stopped responding seemingly unconscious
um
it's an experiment that reveals a lot
about our willingness to compromise our
own concerns or moral judgments in the
face of pressure from a source of
authority I know I'm in a position of
power when I say this to you so I don't
want that to influence
your
willingness to decide I want you to be
honest with me and tell me but it's also
an interesting experiment because an
important part of conducting the
experiment is misdirection if you know
you're in an experiment about the
effects of authority it will influence
how you behave in that experiment but
because ethics you can't just run random
experiments on the unsuspecting public
at least legally you have to get them to
consent to being experimented on you got
to get them to sign Nathan uses this
kind of misdirection all the time in his
work to understand why we need to
understand a dynamic at the very heart
of reality TV
um I've never reveal the name at this
point but
um
in episode one of the rehearsal Nathan
is going to Great Lengths to rehearse
this confession with core my educational
situation is up front and the rehearsals
core is able to spit out the confession
pretty easily over and over again but
when it comes to the real thing this
happens it was the perfect opportunity
to begin his confession but for some
reason he wasn't doing it core seems to
feel the weight of the reality of the
situation and for some reason he seems
to suddenly become very aware of the
presence of the cameras not only might
he be nervous about the outcome of this
moment something Nathan has been going
to extreme lengths to try to prepare him
for but also he's now realizing whatever
happens in this moment will be
permanently recorded and broadcast on TV
adding a whole other layer of anxiety
this is one factor Nathan has failed to
prepare core for it'll feel just like
this yes no surprises no you know
everything that's going to happen
the rehearsal went so far as to try to
give core the experience of the
aftermath of his confession but what is
never rehearsed is the impact having
this kind of personal interaction
broadcast on TV will have on core and
you have to imagine In This Moment the
presence of the cameras is impacting his
behavior I felt a rush of excitement
come over me when I remembered there
were cameras filming me
HBO cameras in a profile for Walter
Nason says if the person knows you're
trying to find out about them then
they're not going to present a real
version you can kind of see this Dynamic
playing out with Angela there are
moments where she seems to want to say
something
and crazy
it's crazy but then catches herself and
says something else no it's good it's
fabulous oh yeah or with Robin he seems
conscious and aware of the cameras at
least at first you might be thinking
these people are willing to do and say
crazy things on camera you don't have a
license plate no
it's okay so why would we think the
presence of the camera is inhibiting
them in some way but the outlandish
things they say and do I think are often
less an element of inhibition and more
that those things are a part of the
identity that they are putting forward
on screen just because the identity
they're presenting seems ridiculous to
you doesn't mean that they're not
self-censoring in some way because of
the camera and sometimes I think the
opposite might even be true instead of
self-censoring the person knowingly or
even unknowingly plays up ridiculous
elements of themselves in front of the
camera I actually think this happens a
lot in all kinds of reality TV where the
participants act a certain way because
they're playing a kind of role the role
not of themselves but of reality TV show
participant and they know this role
intimately because it's been shaped by
the reality TV they've consumed almost
all reality TV selects for in the edit
over-the-top and dramatic characters and
behavior because that's what's
entertaining in doing so it shapes the
expectations audiences have for normal
behavior on reality TV and if you watch
these kind of shows especially enough
that you're interested in being in one
it seems natural then that you'd
consciously or unconsciously lean into
that kind of character because if you're
participating in one of these shows we
know at least one thing about you you
want to be on TV I love being on camera
but I wanted to play it cool like I
didn't care that much you often see
accusations of fakeness or artifice in
reality TV insinuating that the
participants are actors and not real
participants he's an actor he'll be
playing your brother but I think this is
a kind of false dichotomy while very
direct manipulation and scripting does
happen in reality TV is this um
[Music]
you don't need someone to be given a
script or coached by producers for them
to be acting and I wasn't given a lot of
Direction
um I could have been a collaborator with
you on this
more so than than you've let me this
moment is very interesting to me because
it reveals that Angela wanted more
direction that she wanted to be a
collaborator with Nathan in this process
I think we often think of reality TV
show participants as these unwitting
marks being exploited by the producers
and while that's the case in some
scenarios I think a lot of participants
are aware explicitly or implicitly that
they're participating in something that
needs to be entertaining or interesting
yeah I don't know it's uh it's weird but
this is also fascinating so what are you
gonna do
right all of this is actually great for
you if your goal is to produce an
over-the-top dramatic reality TV show
but if your goal is to actually capture
reality people's real or natural
responses to certain situations
something I think Nathan is trying to do
because the whole goal of rehearsing is
to prepare people for real situations
this whole dynamic of people modifying
their behavior consciously or
unconsciously because they know they're
being filmed or they know they're on a
show is a big problem but I've recently
come to realize I've been neglecting one
key component of every crucial life
event
feelings get down on the floor get down
on the floor
in the same TV special where he runs the
Milgram experiment Darren Brown is
trying to convince participants in the
show to commit a robbery they think is
real without them realizing he's
influencing them or that the robbery is
part of the show to pull this off he
tells them that they're participating in
a filmed motivational seminar and gets
them to sign the necessary paperwork for
him to film them over a certain period
of time and then gets real sneaky and
films them when they are unaware they're
being filmed all of this manipulation is
necessary so that you can get them to
legally consent to being filmed while
you're trying to capture their behavior
uninfluenced by the camera it's no
coincidence that this TV special by
Darren Brown was recommended by Nathan
Fielder to the author of that vulture
profile knowing these influences and
that Nathan as a child was interested in
Magic before he got into media you want
to see a card trick or something like a
magic trick helps us understand some of
his tax tactics after today's rehearsal
I had the actor playing Patrick's
brother asked Patrick out of character
to help him move an old Generator at his
Grandpa's Barn when Nathan sets up this
scenario where Patrick is off on an
adventure that to his knowledge is not
actually part of the show despite the
fact that it's still being filmed
they're not filming he's pulling the
same kind of misdirection Darren Brown
is borrowing from the Milgram experiment
and this misdirection really actually
seems to make a difference the impact
that it has on Patrick is clear tired of
living I guess they have to read the
difference between Patrick's response to
these two scenarios is the difference
between what John beaudriard calls
simulacra and simulation and this
distinction is ultimately what pushes
Nathan Fielder to the point where he
worries he's gone too far
well this is
the perfect replica
I mean there's not even the fun house
version of it it has it looks
wow
a simulacra is an image of something a
reflection but Nathan creates for core
is a high fidelity simulacra this chair
is an exact this these wow and that even
even that's
um exactly the way it is but for Nathan
something is still missing in this the
feeling of reality isn't there what he's
striving to achieve with Patrick is not
simulacra but simulation beaudryard in
simulacra and simulation says simulating
is not pretending whoever fakes an
illness can simply stay in bed and make
everyone believe he is ill whoever
simulates an illness produces in himself
some of the symptoms what's that
simulation apart is that simulation
feels real to the participants on the
flip side those inside a simulacra have
knowledge that they're pretending but
you can't orchestrate a simulation from
the inside knowledge that you're in a
simulation disrupts it this is the
problem that Nathan runs into when he
makes the rehearsal about himself and
his own experience he tries to create a
simulation of reality for himself by
striving forever greater levels of
detail in that simulation
I was thinking of calling it
at SUNY Lake room
I don't even know what it means it's an
actor key New York Caden runs into the
same problem he wants to create a play
that is truly honest that reflects
reality in some kind of fundamental way
tell me why you're here 11.
following you for 20 years
so I knew about this Edition because I
follow you
and I've learned everything about you by
following you
so hire me
and you'll see who you truly are
his attempts to do this lead him away
from creating an image of reality
towards creating a simulation of reality
well
it up
all of it
once this simulation reaches a certain
level of detail Caden's real life and
the simulation of his life become
indistinguishable
therefore pretending leaves the
principal reality intact the difference
is always clear it is simply masked
whereas simulation threatens the
difference between true and false the
real and the imaginary when we can't
distinguish between the real and the
imaginary the simulation and reality
itself have imploded beaujiard calls
this implosion this environment where we
lose the ability to distinguish between
the real and the imaginary the hyper
real
where is it
oh hi hi I'm here to see the doctor
eye doctor farts can I have a seat Dr
farts AKA Remy is hired as an actor to
play Adam the child that Nathan and
Angela are raising in their simulacra of
a home who am I
[Music]
who am I
Daddy but there's a hiccup unknown to
Nathan Remy in real life doesn't have a
dad and wants one and during his time as
Nathan's pretend son Remy is young
enough that he doesn't understand all
the lines between true and false reality
and fiction for him what is meant to be
a simulacra becomes a simulation he
doesn't have a real dad during this time
but as beaudryard put it he has all the
symptoms of having a real dad someone
who spends time with him encourages his
creativity and says I love you what did
you say oh love you Daddy oh I love you
too Adam this is where Nathan comes face
to face with the reality of what he's
doing the ethical dangers of blurring
the lines between simulacra and
simulation I spent a week with a child
who had no dad pretending that I was his
dad what did I think was gonna happen
and for the first time he's forced to
feel something responsibility or remorse
maybe Nathan is brought out of his world
of simulacra by a genuine human feeling
and interaction with a real person in
the real world but something happens
here on the show that's important and it
relates to one of the fundamental
elements of reality TV we'll call it
never questioned the premise
you'll know you'll know what exactly to
say for every possible then that would
be extremely appealing yes every reality
TV show is predicated on some kind of
premise or scenario Netflix is full of
reality TV where the hook is the
absolutely ridiculous premise that is
used to create drama and entertainment
in Love is Blind couples that have never
seen each other agree to get married
within a matter of weeks but there's an
interesting thing that often happens on
this show or others like it or some of
the participants back out or Express
concerns that on some level can be
boiled down to things are moving too
quickly or I don't really know this
person it's only been five days oh my
god I've had meals in my refrigerator
for longer than that like that's crazy
participants in the show might Express
these kinds of vague feelings but what's
important the critical role that almost
every reality TV show lives by is don't
question the premise of the show when
someone on Love is Blind is like yeah
this person seems great but I'm not sure
I want to marry them right now because
hey I've only known them for two weeks
the show never points out or allows the
participants to explicitly acknowledge
that this problem is directly created by
the very structure and premise of the
show the drama is not between the two
people the drama is between the
participant and the structure of the
show from the show's perspective it's
best to just move on and forget about it
or try to pass it off as something else
like hmm weird I guess they're afraid of
commitment or something like I'm scared
that it's not gonna last because to
point out that this conflict is created
by the completely artificial structure
of the premise is to point out how
utterly artificial and ridiculous the
entire trauma is
Nathan represents this tension perfectly
in the rehearsal while he's constantly
unpacking and deconstructing elements of
the reality TV format like the Dynamics
of power created by the camera it's all
standard signature is on the fourth page
right sorry yeah okay great we'll see
you tomorrow yeah or the enticement for
the participants of appearing on TV he
never questions his own core premise for
the show that premise of rehearsal the
idea that trying to avoid unpleasant
Feelings by trying to control every
detail of an interaction before it
happens is a productive or helpful way
to navigate life when Nathan seems to
encounter the real-life feelings created
by the situation with Dr farts he
ultimately doesn't approach the
situation in a genuine way but instead
continues to rehearse forcing himself
back into the very trap that caused all
of these problems to begin with
just when you think Nathan might be
reaching some level of insight about the
situation we get this
Charlie
don't forget what happened to the man
who suddenly got everything he always
wanted what happened
he lived happily ever after
[Music]
there's a music video from 2016 called
cliches by the French artist hero fonte
that I returned to periodically and it
inevitably leaves me with a kind of
existential queasiness the Instagram
account insta repeat is a more recent
documentation of this same phenomenon
when we take and post an Instagram photo
are we trying to capture a reflection of
our real life are we crafting a
simulacra or are we instead creating an
image that is a reflection of the kind
of life that we've seen in other images
and that we want to be living
um
how real is the rehearsal I think there
are many elements of genuine unscripted
moments that crop up in the show and
perhaps with the help of Nathan's
Milgram experiment style misdirection
participants like Patrick uncover some
real emotions in response to scenarios
but all of this exists to us the viewer
within Nathan's simulated world I don't
mean it exists within the world of the
sets that he built that real people
walked around in I mean the world of the
video file that we're pressing play on
on HBO we the viewers don't see the
actual events as they happened we see a
simulacra of the events that took place
in the real world a simulacra called the
rehearsal it's an image shaped and
created by Nathan Fielder and not Nathan
Fielder the character on the show a
real-life Nathan Fielder that we never
get to see when viewing the show it's
impossible to escape the narrative frame
of the show a narrative frame created by
somebody who is openly manipulative
reality TV Productions are usually very
secretive we don't get behind the scenes
material like we do for a lot of fiction
films and shows participants are almost
always required to sign non-disclosure
agreements limiting them from talking
about their experience on the show or
aspects of the production much of this
is I think because like a magic trick
once you know how the trick is done it
doesn't seem so impressive Nathan has a
problem with lying he lies a lot
always in the back of my mind is the
fact that perhaps the real Mark here for
Nathan's manipulations is not just core
Angela or Patrick but us the viewers we
can see in places that divide between
Nathan the character on the show and the
real Nathan in the real world the real
Nathan who's producing the show
orchestrates and acts out these
scenarios where his character on the
show goes right up against a realization
about the questionable nature of what
he's doing reliving the day again as
Thomas made me realize there was a whole
other layer to his experience I hadn't
considered but the Nathan who's on
screen and who's in the voiceover the
character may be the best use of my
resources at this point would be to
figure out what I could have done
differently doesn't actually learn from
these realizations and each time instead
of changing his behavior doubles down on
the thing that caused the problem in the
first place and I wondered if I was
going far enough and this is played
multiple times throughout the series as
a joke and I began to question the
tactics this teacher was encouraging
so I suggested to Thomas that he move
into an apartment that reflects the
living situation of his primary the real
world Nathan obviously gets the lesson
the character of Nathan is failing to
learn because otherwise the real world
Nathan wouldn't be able to use his
character failing to learn that lesson
as a joke I'm as invested as I can be
but this is all sort of absurd right
and as we descend deeper into the show
seemingly unsuspecting participants from
outside of the rehearsals like course
friend Trish are no longer even present
and many scenes are just Nathan and
other actors acting out a scenario like
we're just acting yeah you know that
right yeah yeah and yet the whole style
and presentation of the show still
represents these moments as if they are
being captured spontaneously when we
watch a show like this if we forget that
we're only seeing a simulacra and not
the real we can enter into a hyper
reality of the show where the line
between the real and the manipulated is
impossible for us to really determine
all we're left with is speculation I
think we shouldn't have done that show
huh it's like a weird thing for a little
kid to be a part of
the most real Nathan seems to be on the
show is when the doctor fart situation
seems to genuinely make him question
what he's doing
[Music]
remember
we're just pretending and maybe the real
life Nathan actually learned something
here and handled the situation with
emotional maturity I'm I was the problem
not you but in the Arc of the show the
character of Nathan does not learn his
lesson did you get enough yeah I think
so okay good talk a lot
[Music]
thank you
but do we it's not just reality TV that
generates the hyper real while many of
us will never participate in reality TV
many of us try to craft an image of Our
Lives that we present to the world
social media goes from being a place
where we present reflections of our real
selves to simulations of social
environments that we participate in
simulations we increasingly treat as
real we can easily get lost in these
simulations in this hyper real world of
images and in doing so Overlook the real
that's right in front of us the entire
time sometimes to get to that reality we
have to question the premise
it was a work of art and it was just
real life
Daddy
family romance LLC is a Werner Herzog
film about a Japanese company that hires
out actors to play the role of family
members in funerals or other significant
life events and it's a movie that delves
deeper into this world of hyper reality
you can watch it right now on mubi my
sponsor for this video mubi is an online
hand curated streaming service with an
exceptional selection of Cinema from all
around the world to have an amazing
selection that they add to every day
they're very careful about what they
choose and increasingly they release
movies themselves like with family
romance LLC and some upcoming films
which I got to see at can and really
enjoyed you can get a 30-day extended
free trial to mubi right now when you go
to mubi.com thomasflight that's mubi.com
thomasflight newbie is not only a great
place to watch Cinema but a great one to
Discover It click the link in the
description or on the screen to try mubi
for free today
foreign
Thomas
[Music]
[Applause]